the word size kind of loses its meaning
on the quantum level allow me to explain
for particles made of smaller particles
size is pretty straightforward a proton
is made of quarks and gluons the
distance between those parts gives us a
sense of size but there are also
Elementary particles those are particles
that aren't made of smaller particles
how do you define size for something
without Parts where are the edges we
could say the edges are where the
interactions happen but then an electron
is the size of an entire atom that can't
be right atoms tend to have multiple
electrons how can they all be the size
of an atom they'd occupy the same space
at the same time
to make matters worse when we measure
where one of them is it suddenly
collapses into a space a hundred million
times smaller size is a fluid concept
for an electron